this technology is really looking at how
can we collect information about
everyday behavior by instrumenting that
artifacts that people interact with in
an everyday behavior so we have things
like a pillbox right this is basically a
five-dollar pillbox 77 days pillbox that
you can buy from riteaid exactly too
they're just super glued back to back so
on one side as you can see in the image
there's batteries and their sensors and
there's there's hardware all in here but
on the other side it's basically a
regular pillbox right and so what kind
of information can we collect for this
we're really interesting collecting to
two kinds of information that are to
data with two particular characteristics
this data set up is really meant to help
us understand and push NSS cognitive
decline in elders in seniors so how can
we instrument their everyday activities
instrument the artifacts they use on an
everyday basis to be able to collect
information about cognitive decline the
second thing that we're really
interested in is how to do it in a way
that doesn't affect how they perform
those activities so we took three of
those instrumental activities of daily
living ones that we thought we could
sense relatively easily and ones that
were that where they provided some
concrete value to our subjects to our
users and so the key thing behind the
technology because there's plenty of
pill boxes out there that will tell you
whether someone's been successful at
taking their medicine there's a pill
pill bottles there's other things that
look like this that collect information
about whether you're successful and we
care a little bit less about whether you
were successful or not then about the
quality of your performance so one of
the things you notice with if you
haven't if you have an elder elderly
parent or a loved one that's undergoing
cognitive decline is that the decline
that the changes in the performance
actually occurs much earlier than you
see them making mistakes right someone
can be perfectly successful at taking
their medicine but the quality of the
performance of taking that medicine may
it be exhibited long before they start
having problems so let me give you a
concrete example so you may have a pair
that is having difficulty remembering
what day of the week it is right so
their sensors on here that can basically
tell you okay the open sunday the open
Monday and now they've opened Tuesday
which is today right so they got it they
got it right they were successfully
taking their medicine but what the
system is able to capture is how well
the performance of that activity was so
there's lots of sensors in here there's
things to let us know when the door has
been open there's accelerometers in here
to let you know when it's been turned
over if there's sensors in here to let
us know when they're having physically
dipped physical difficulty as I am right
now in opening this box